hello peter how can i help you hey um  let's just start with my glasses coming  in peter i'm having difficulty hearing  you can you please speak up  um brad davis he has a photo of me brad  davis is he a target is brad a target um  yeah he's a target he's a target copy  that  target is brad davis initiating strike  what now intercept point determined  releasing kill vehicle eat it  [Music]  so  peter do you want me to cancel the drone  strike on brad did you just punch flash  no firing  [Music]  [Music]  commencing second strike peter plant  your fanny in that seat and buckle up  right now look at the baby bounce baby  [Music]  i don't see any mountain goats you  missed them  i know you think none of us have noticed  peter what  but your new look  i love it  right babe thanks yeah sophisticated  classy very european  [Music]  you